The first piece of art that I was
intensely interested in,
the first thing that affected me so
powerful that I was driven to understand
why sweeping epic about the Lord of
dreams that started me on a path that's
led to here dream or Morphea says he's
most commonly called in the series,
has done the same for a lot of people.
Indeed,
when game and made his lead character,
the personification and master of
dreams,
he played on both meanings of the word,
the visions we have one asleep and the
wishes that consume us when awake.
There is so much to explore and Sandman
and I may do more on this,
but today I want to zero in on the
unique place that William Shakespeare
has in the series and how his presence
helps game and communicate some themes
about writing dreams and genius.
Shakespeare makes three appearances in
San man's 75 issues the first time we
see them as toward the beginning of the
series in the context of another
person's story dream and his sister
death make an agreement in a 14th
century tavern when they overhear a man
saying that.
The only reason people die is because
everyone does it.
Death agrees not to take this man hub
gasoline until he desires it and dream
agrees to meet him in the same bar once
every hundred years to discuss how he's
feeling on their second meeting in 15,
89 dream and hop over here,
a man name will shack spurred pining to
his friend and fellow playwright,
Kit Marlowe about his great wish to give
men dreams that would live on after I'm
dead.
So dream strikes,
another bargain with him,
the details of which we learn on their
second meeting.
This time on the south downs of Sussex,
England,
where Shakespeare traveling with a
troupe of players is preparing his new
play of midsummer night's dream display
we learned was written for dream one of
two plays about dreams in exchange for
Shakespeare becoming the figure we know
today the vessel for the great stories
of mankind,
Shakespeare's troop are enticed to
perform for the real inhabitants of
fairy were visiting the earthly realm at
dreams invitation.
Perhaps for the last time in the process
of this story which takes place toward
the middle of the series.
Dream begins to question if he was right
for giving shakespeare what he wanted.
He did not understand the cost.
He says,
mortals never do.
They only see the prize,
their heart's desire,
their dream,
but the price of getting what you want
is getting what you once wanted.
Here we begin to see the purpose behind
Shakespeare's inclusion in this series
through Shakespeare and analog for dream
and Gaiman himself.
We get a meditation not only on genius,
but on the cost of genius.
The for gaming.
That cost is isolation,
isolation of all forms.
In this issue,
we meet him,
Shakespeare son,
Shakespeare seems to regard him as a
nuisance and Hamnett laments to another
actor.
He's very distant.
He doesn't seem like he's really there
anymore.
Not really.
It's like he's somewhere else.
Anything that happens,
he just make stories out of it.
I'm less real than any of the characters
in his place.
In his eagerness to write great stories.
Shakespeare becomes isolated from his
family and his life,
such as the cost of extreme focus,
but works of genius also become isolated
from their context.
At the intermission of the play,
dream breaks the news to Shakespeare
that his friend Christopher Marlowe has
been killed.
The timing is no accident here.
The rise of Shakespeare beginning with
plays like a midsummer night's dream
signaled the disappearance of his
contemporaries like Christopher Marlowe
from the historical record in modern
cultural memory.
Barring academia,
their presence has been overshadowed by
isolated genius game and picks up this
theme again in the final appearance of
Shakespeare in Sandman,
which is also not accidentally the final
issue of the series.
Here Shakespeare is writing his final
play,
the tempest,
the second play at the end of his career
that fulfills his bargain with dream.
His friend and sometimes critic Ben
Johnson comes to visit him and asks
about the new play.
Have you been rating poor Holland shed
again,
or does plutarch's bear the brunt of
your depredations?
This of course references the fact that
Shakespeare famously took many of his
plots from prior sources and histories
like those of Rafael Holland shed and
plutarch.
Yet these sources like small planets
like Christopher Marlowe and Ben
Johnson,
do not register against the massive
star.
That is Shakespeare.
An example,
back in the first issue in 1789 at their
fourth meeting,
Hob gambling tells dream he has seen a
production of King Lear mentioning the
idiots have given it a happy ending that
will not last dream says the great
stories will always return to their
original forms.
Here Gaiman is playing with us.
He knows what the average man epitomized
by hop gatling does,
not that it was shakespeare who changed
the ending.
The original versions on which lear was
base did have a happy ending,
but those versions are for God,
and yet by having dreams say the great
stories will always return to their
original forms.
Gaming indicates perhaps the key theme
of the whole series,
the power of dreams to supplant reality.
In the second issue,
Oberon King of fairy watches
Shakespeare's play about himself and
says to dream what but things never
happened.
Thus,
dream responds apropos of this theme,
things need not have happened to be
true.
Tales and dreams are the shadow truths
that will endure when mere facts are
dust and ashes and forgot.
The very next panel features the line
from a midsummer night's dream that
criticizes the power of stories,
the best in this kind or but shadows
gaming like Shakespeare disagrees,
the shadows,
these illusions of reality incomplete as
they are may come in time to replace the
real thing.
Indeed,
Shakespeare was the vessel for extremely
powerful stories.
His treatments of culture,
of love and madness in many ways created
the age we still live in.
We are all in a very real sense living
in the dreams of Shakespeare.
Sandman is a singular work of art coming
and propelling comics into a higher
literary appreciation and pulling like
Shakespeare's work on a vast catalog of
mythological,
religious and literary references.
It's fitting that gaming is more
interested in Shakespeare,
the man that his work Shakespeare dream
and game and like I said,
are all analogs for one another and each
in their turn have to examine the costs
of telling great stories.
The largest part of that cost,
it seems is isolation.
I watched my life as if it were
happening to someone else.
Shakespeare tell street my son died and
I was hurt,
but I watched my hurt and even relished
it a little for now,
I could write a real death,
a true loss in three issues that span
the series.
Neil gaiman treats these themes of
genius and isolation within a larger
framework of a story that is essentially
about stories.
The inclusion of Shakespeare highlights
the uneasy relationship between stories,
collective dreams,
and those who create them.
History and imagination,
amend Shakespeare to fit their purposes
just as Gaiman does,
by bringing him to life in the pages of
Sandman and game and imagines him
isolated from his own life as history
has isolated him above his time and
place even as we make our work,
our work makes us and it can obliterate
us to.
In other words,
dreams really do
come true.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching and welcome to
everybody who is new to the nerd writer
that inside out video.
I can't believe so many people watched
that.
That was just an awesome experience last
week,
but this is a great example of the kind
of stuff we do here.
The nerd writer,
we take art and culture and science and
politics and explore them and go in
depth and put ideas to work and that's
what this is all about.
And the channel is made possible by your
pledges on my Patrion page right here,
this little as a dollar per video,
you know,
the money that you guys give me goes
directly into these videos,
um,
and to,
toward improving the channel.
And that is really what I want to do is
push this medium farther,
you know,
create new styles,
new ways of exploring and explaining
ideas.
And there's a lot more than I want to
do.
This was awesome.
I've been thinking about how to analyze
comics for a long time.
Hope you enjoyed it.
And anyway,
thank you again and welcome to the nerd
writer.
We have a lot of fun here.
Um,
I will see you guys next Wednesday.